So speaking of Shakespeare I've recently
gotten to know Neri oxman who's this
incredible uh scientist that works at
the intersection of Nature and
engineering and
she uh reminded me of this uh Anna
ahmatava Line This is this great Soviet
poet that I really love from uh over a
century ago that each of Our Lives is a
Shakespearean drama race to the Thousand
degree so I have to ask why do you think
humans are attracted to
this kind of Shakespearean drama
is there some aspect we've been talking
about the subconscious mind that that
pulls us towards
the drama even though the place of
mental health is peace
yes and yes do you have some of the draw
towards drama
yeah
if you look at the empirical data yes I
mean right if I look at the empirical
data I mean I think about who I chose to
work for as an undergraduate right I was
a you know barely finished high school
finally get to College
barely I think this is really
embarrassing and not something to Aspire
to you know I was
um you know thrown out of the dorms for
fighting
um necessarily past my classes you know
the girlfriend and I split up I mean I
was living in a squad got into a big
fight it was getting in trouble with the
law I eventually got my act together go
back to school start working for
somebody who do I choose to work for a
guy who's an ex-navy guy who smokes
cigarettes in the fume Hood drinks
coffee and we're injecting rats with
MDMA yeah and you know I was drawn to
like the personality his energy but I
also he was a great he was a great
scientist worked out a lot on a thermal
regulation in the brain and
um and more
um you know go to graduate school I'm
working for somebody and
decide that yeah doing working in her
laboratory wasn't quite right for me so
I'm literally sneaking into the
laboratory next door and working for the
woman next door because I like the
relationships that she had to a certain
set of questions and she was a kind of a
quirky person and you know so drawn to
drama but drawn to I like characters I
like people that have texture yeah and
I'm not drawn to Raw ambition I'm
drawing people that seem to have a real
passion for what they do and a
uniqueness to them that I I you know you
can kind of not kind of I'll just say
how it is I can feel their heart for
what they do and I'm I'm drawn to that
like um and that can be good
the same reason I went to work for Ben
Barris as a postdoc it wasn't because he
was the first transgender Man member of
the National Academy of Sciences that
was just a feature of who he was I loved
how he loved glea he would talk about
these cells like they were the most
enchanting things that he'd ever seen in
his life and I was like this is like the
biggest nerd I've ever met and I love
him
I think we're Dr I'm drawn to that
um this is another thing that Conti
makes uh elaborates on quite a bit more
in the series on Mental Health coming
out but there are different drives
within us there's this
there are aggressive drives not always
for fighting but for intense interaction
I mean look at Twitter look at some of
look at people clearly have an
aggressive Drive there's also a pleasure
Drive some people also have a strong
pleasure Drive they want to experience
pleasure through food through sex
through friendship through Adventure you
know but I think the Shakespearean drama
is the drama of the different drives in
different ratios in different people I I
know somebody and she's incredibly kind
has an extremely high pleasure Drive
loves taking great care of herself and
people around her through food and
through Retreats and through all these
things and makes spaces beautiful
everywhere she goes and is gifts these
things that are just so unbelievably
feminine and incredible these gifts to
people and the kind and thoughtful about
what they like and then
um but I would say very little
aggressive Drive
um from my read and then I know other
people who are just have a ton of
aggressive drive and very low pleasure
drive and I think so there's this
alchemy that exists where people have
these things in different ratios and
then you blend in
um you know the differences in the
chromosomes and differences in hormones
and differences in personal history and
what you end up with is a species
that
creates incredible recipes of drama but
also peace also relief from drama
contentment I mean I realize this isn't
the exact topic of the question but
um someone I know
very dearly actually an ex-girlfriend of
mine long-term partner mine
um sent me something recently I think it
hit the nail on the head which is that
ideally
for a man they eventually settle where
they find and feel peace or they feel
peaceful where they can be themselves
and feel peaceful now I'm sure there's a
equivalent or mirror image of that for
women but this particular post that she
sent was about men and I totally agree
and so
um it isn't always that we're seeking
friction but for periods of our life we
see friction drama Adventure excitement
fights
um you know
and doing hard hard things and then I
think at some point I'm certainly coming
to this point now where it's like yeah
that's all great and checked a lot of
boxes but had a lot of close calls flew
really close to the Sun on a lot of
things with life and limb and and part
and spirit and some of them you know
people close to us didn't make it and
sometimes not making it means their the
career they wanted went off a cliff or
the the their health went off a cliff or
their life went off a cliff but I think
that
um there's also the Shakespearean drama
of the characters that exit the play and
are living their lives happily in the
backdrop it just doesn't make for as
much entertainment
that's one other thing that's a benefit
you could say is the benefit of getting
older is uh
um finding the Shakespearean drama less
appealing or finding the joy in the
peace yeah definitely I mean I think
that
um I think there's real peace with age I
think the other thing is this notion of
checking boxes is a real thing I for me
anyway I I have a morning meditation
that I do
um well I wake up now I get my sunlight
I hydrate I use the bathroom I do all
the things that I talk about
um I've started to practice a prayer in
the last year which is new ish for me
which is we could talk about in the
morning yeah can you talk about it a
little bit sure yeah and I and then I
have a meditation that I do that
actually is where I think through with
the different roles that I play so I
like I start very basic
um I say okay I'm an animal like we are
we are like biologically animals right
human
you know I'm a man I'm a scientist I'm a
teacher I'm a friend I'm a brother I'm a
son you know I go through this I have
this list and I think about the
different roles that I have and the
roles that I still want in my life going
forward that I haven't yet fulfilled it
just takes me it's sort of an inventory
of where I've been where I'm at and
where I'm going as they say
um and I don't know why I do it but I
started doing it this last year I think
because
um it helps me understand just how many
different uh contexts I have to exist in
and and remind myself that there's still
more that I haven't done that I'm
excited about So within each of those
contexts there's like things that you
want to kind of accomplish to Define
that yeah and I'm ambitious so I think
you know I'm a brother I have an older
sister and I love her tremendously and I
think I want to be the best brother I
can be to her which means maybe a call
maybe just
um you know we do an annual trip
together for our birthdays our birthdays
are close together we always go to New
York for our birthdays if we've gone for
last three four years like really like
reminding myself of that role not
because I'll forget but because I have
all these other roles I'll get pulled
into I say the first one I'm an animal
because I have to remember that I have a
body that needs care
like any of us I need sleep I need food
I need hydration I need that I'm human
that that the brain of a human is is
marvelously complex but also
um marvelously uh self-defeating at
times and so I've been thinking about
these things in the context of the
different roles and the whole thing
takes about four or five minutes and I
just find it brings me a certain amount
of clarity that then allows me to
ratchet into the day the prayer piece um
yeah I think I've been reluctant to talk
about
um until now
um because I don't believe in pushing
religion on people and
um and I think that
um and I'm not
um it's a highly individual thing and I
do believe that one can be an atheist
and still pray
um or agnostic and still pray but uh for
me it really came about through
understanding that there are certain
aspects of myself
that I just couldn't
resolve on my own and no matter how much
therapy no matter how much and I haven't
done a lot of it but no matter how much
plant medicine or other sorts of
medicine or exercise or
um podcasting or science or
friendship or any of that I was just not
going to resolve and so
um I started this because uh someone
close to me
um said a male friend said you know
prayer is powerful
and I said well how and I said I don't
know how but if you if you can get it
can allow you to Get outside yourself
get let you give up control and at the
same time take control I don't even like
saying take control but the whole notion
is that
again forgive me but there's no other
way to say it the whole notion is that
you know like God works through US
whatever God is to you he he him her
whatever the life force nature whatever
it is to you right that it works through
us and so I do a prayer I'll just
describe it where I I ask
um I make an ask to help remove my
defects my Character defects I I pray to
God to help remove my Character defects
so that I can show up
um better in all the roles of my life
and do good work like to which for me is
learning and teaching learning and
teaching and and so you might say well
how is that different than a meditation
well it I'm acknowledging that there is
something that bigger than me bigger
than nature as I understand it that I
cannot understand or control nor do I
want to and I'm just giving over to that
and does that make me less of a
scientist I I sure tell hope not I
certainly know I there's the head of our
neurosciences at Stanford until recently
um I you should talk to him directly
about it Bill Newsom has talked about
his religious life
um for me it's really a way of getting
outside myself and then understanding
how I fit into this bigger picture and
it's and the Character defects part is
real right I'm a human I have defects
like
I got a lot of flaws in me like anybody
but
um and trying to acknowledge them and
asking for help in removing them not
magically but through right action
through my right action
so I do that every morning and um I have
to say that it's helped it's helped a
lot it's helped me be better to myself
be better at other people
um I still make mistakes
um but it's a it's becoming a bigger
bigger part of my life and I never
thought I'd talk like this
um but
I think
it's clear to me that
if we don't
believe in something
again doesn't have to be traditional
standardized religion but if we don't
believe in something bigger than
ourselves we uh at some level will
self-destruct
I really I really think so it's power
and it's powerful in a way that all the
other stuff meditation and all the tools
is is not because it's really operating
at a much deeper and bigger level and um
you know if
yeah I think I think that's all I I can
talk about it
um mostly because I'm still working out
you know the scientists in me wants to
understand how it works and I want to
understand and the point is to just go
you know there's some there's you know
for lack of a better language for it
there's higher power than me and what I
can control I'm giving up control on
certain things and somehow that restores
a sense of agency
for for right action better action I
think perhaps a part of that is just the
humility that comes with acknowledging
there's something bigger and more
powerful than you and then you can't
control everything yeah it's I mean that
you go through life as a hard driving
person you know forward Center of mass I
remember being that way since I was
little it's like in Legos I'm like all
Legos I was like on the weekends you
know learning about medieval weapons and
giving lectures about it in class when I
was five or six years old we're learning
about tropical fish and you know
cataloging all of them at the store and
then organizing it and making my you
know my dad drive me or my mom drive me
to some fish store and then spending all
my time there until they throw me out
you know all of that but I also remember
my entire life I would secretly pray
when things were good and things weren't
good but mostly when things weren't good
because it's important to pray for me
it's important to pray each morning
regardless but when things
weren't right I couldn't make sense of
them I would secretly pray but I felt
kind of ashamed of that for whatever
reason and then it was once in college I
distinctly remember I I was having a
hard time with a number of things
um and I took a run
down to Sands beaches UC Santa Barbara
and I remember I just I was like I don't
know if I even have the right to to do
this but I'm just praying I just prayed
for
uh
the ability to be as brutally honest
with myself
and with other people as I possibly
could be about a particular situation I
was in at that time
I mean I I think now it's probably safe
to say I got off to college because of a
high school girlfriend we'd essentially
she was my family more frankly more than
my biological family was at a certain
stage of life and we'd reached a point
where we were diverging and it was it
was incredibly painful it was like
losing everything I had and I was like
what do I do how do I manage this do I
you know I was ready to quit and join
the Fire Service just to support us so
we could move forward and and
um and you know it's just but praying
for just saying I can't figure this out
on my own it's sort of like I can't
think of this out on my own and how
frustrating that is no number of friends
could tell me or and inner wisdom
couldn't tell me and eventually led me
to the right answers and she and I are
friendly friends to this day she's
happily married with a child and
um we're on good terms but I think
you know it's
it's a it's a scary thing but it's the
best thing when you I can't control all
this and asking for help I think is also
the piece you're not asking for some
magic hand to come down and take care of
it you're asking for the help to come
through you right so that your body is
used to do these right works right
action isn't it interesting that this
secret thing that you're almost
embarrassed by that you did it as a
child is something you oh man it's
another thing you do as you get older is
you realize like those things are part
of you and it's actually a beautiful
thing yeah a lot of the content of the
podcast is you know deep epic content
and we talk about everything from you
know uh Eating Disorders to bipolar
disorder to depression you know a lot of
different topics but the tools are the
protocols as we say right the sunlight
viewing all the rest
um you know a lot of that stuff is just
stuff I wish I had known when I was in
graduate school if I'd known to go
outside every once in a while and get
some sunlight not just stay in the lab
I would have you know I might not have
hit a like a really tough round of
depression when I was a postdoc and
working twice as hard and you know when
my body would break down or I'd get sick
a lot I don't get sick Much Anymore
occasionally about once every 18 months
to two years I get I'll get something
but
um
learn you know I used to break my foot
skateboarding all the time I couldn't
understand what's wrong with my body I'm
getting injured I can't do what everyone
else can now I developed more slowly at
a long Arc of puberty
um but I so that was part of it I was
still developing but you know how to get
your body stronger how to build
endurance that no one told me the
information wasn't there so a lot of
what I put out there is the information
that I wish I had had because once I had
it I was like wow like a this stuff
really works B it's grounded in
something real you know some place
sometimes certain Protocols are a
combination of you know animal human and
animal and human studies sometimes
clinical trials sometimes there's some
mechanistic conjecture for some not all
I always make clear which but in the end
like
figuring out how things work so that we
can be happier healthier more productive
suffer less like reduce the suffering of
the world
um and I think that
well I'll just say thank you and um for
asking about the prayer piece
um
again I'm not pushing or even
encouraging it on anyone I've just found
it to be tremendously useful for me